[Musique]
pardon madame savez vous ce que c'est un
fast food
non parce que c est ce que vous savez ce
que c'est un fast food en face fast food
connais pas ce drame usa passe outre je
pense fast food
savez vous ce que c'est je vois les
humeurs
pardon monsieur savez vous ce que face
aux autres pardon madame monsieur
pendant monsieur qu'est ce que micro
qu'est ce que le fast-food pardon fast
food ne m'intéresse pas je suis pour
mais j'ai rapidement un endroit où on
sert des espèces de brioches avec dedans
du steak haché et nourriture rapide
savez vous ce qu'est un fast food non
alors là je vois pas
je vois pas
tu rapide
qu'il suffit
savez vous ce qu'est un fast food un
fast-food savez vous ce que le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que les faso ne
sont pas très connus c'est en 1972 que
les premiers restaurants rapides à base
de hamburgers souvent en france en effet
la célèbre firme américaine et gérés en
franchise
l'entreprise n'est pas très concluante
comme lampe revue les américains mais
quand en 1978 l affaire commence à
rapporter ses fruits les américains
essayent de reprendre leurs droits et
par là même le marché français ce qu'ils
parviennent à faire au terme d'un long
procès récemment terminé le fast-food
entre désormais dans les moeurs des
français pourtant si fier dans la
gastronomie de renommée mondiale
ce système de restauration rapide va
désormais envahir la france toulouse
vire à la firme américaine ouvrir ses
portes fin 80 et plus récemment la firme
quick française enfin 83
nous commençons comme il se doit par le
père du fast food
la société macdonald en effet celle ci
est fondée en 1955 par raycroft
récemment décédé il est à l'origine de
cette nouvelle formule de restauration
rapide
la société ne cesse depuis de
s'accroître 1955 premier restaurant à
chicago aujourd'hui 7300 restaurants
dans le monde entier dont 80 % aux usa
en 30 ans mcdonald's a dépassé les 45
milliards de hamburgers soit trois fois
la distance terre-lune
il est coté en bourse et possède même
son université de hamburg au logis cette
réussite a été concrétisée à la suite de
nombreux efforts vous savez que le mac
donald's a été créé en 1955 dans
l'illinois et depuis ce temps là
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses ont été
améliorées bien entendu pour servir
beaucoup mieux le client en respectant
nos fameuses normes d'hygiène et de
qualité des produits de notre politique
restera toujours la même
et notre devise est bien entendu la
qualité les services seront toujours
égaux à eux mêmes
je pense que c'est pour les deux raisons
il ya des gens qui viennent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas le temps de rentrer chez eux
parce qu'ils ont la flemme de préparer à
manger et beaucoup d'autres qui viennent
par mois 2 surtout volés en ce qui
concerne les jeunes et tous les
habitudes ah oui beaucoup d'habitués
disons qu'on voit régulièrement venir le
midi et le soir
face au succès de mcdonald's autres
restaurants ouvrent leurs portes
la société quick filiale de casino ouvre
son premier restaurant une réussite
considérable en trois ans 33 restaurants
se sont ouvert fondé sur la même formule
que mcdonald's quick est actuellement le
leader français de cette restauration
rapide à base d'un burger et depuis peu
donc à toulouse à casino outre ces
cafétérias intégrer ou non dans les
centres commerciaux a décidé de se
lancer dans la restauration rapide à
base de longueur en grand déclic
nombreux restaurants ont fait tirer pour
l'avenir
perspectives sont multiples sur la
france entière bien sûr possédant déjà
33 restaurants sont sur la région en
1984 en ouvrir au moins deux de plus sur
la région toulousaine et nous pensons
les ouvriers avec la formule driving qui
comme vous le savez est une formule qui
nous permet de servir nos clients en
voiture comme c'est le cas actuellement
au centre var newt de marseille
quoi qu'il en soit fast food à
l'américaine fast food à la française
n'est ce pas finalement la même chose
mais il n'y aura-t-il pas toulouse une
guerre des places plein soultz andric
les français place du capitole avec les
américains
[Musique]